- If you think, you know,
Johnny49 from Alabama is
gonna stop me cursing,
you have no idea how I grew up. (laughs)
(R&B music)
You've got your perspective.
(applause)
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(R&B music)
There's this level of not understanding
the importance of the scaled creative,
and more importantly the
way I think about it,
there's gonna be a culture of making.
♪ I gave you all my heart ♪
♪ But did you even notice it ♪
♪ Every verse I write I put
my heart and my soul in it ♪
- The biggest thing that
I wanna accomplish is A,
answer any detailed question.
I want to really do
that, and please ask it.
Like, hey this is not
gonna work here because,
or I don't see how, you know, like,
that's what this is about.
But the other thing is for everybody
to understand like deeply why.
This is gonna happen with or without us.
Literally if we all disappear tomorrow.
Like no Vayner.
I quit, you quit, we all quit.
No Vayner.
This model is going to win the
day in this industry in 2021.
I promise you.
Promise.
So, I just wish it's us, I hope it's us.
Once you actually see it,
it's just hard to unsee.
Because then everything
else feels like a disaster.
♪ Cry myself to sleep when
that record label ain't call ♪
♪ I ain't perfect but I'm
more than what you asked for ♪
♪ I've got fans why the
hell I'm feeling sad for ♪
♪ All I ever wanted was a platform ♪
♪ This one for Meek Mills
management and I rap for ♪
(audience cheers)
- Thank you.
Thank you.
Sit, sit, sit.
- [Audience] Gary, Gary, Gary.
- Let me talk.
You've been waiting two
fucking days for this so, fuck.
Sorry about that.
What I'm fascinated by
is that everybody here,
how many people here
have been following me
for more than one year?
Raise your hand.
The fact that 90% of this audience knows
that all I want you to do is run Facebook
and Instagram ads and you still aren't,
makes me want to punch all
of you in your fucking face.
(audience laughs)
I mean, literally all
I've been asking you to do
for the last two years is run
Facebook and Instagram ads,
and you fuck-faces still aren't.
(audience laughs)
And I say this because I put it on film,
because I'm going to run
this exact video against you,
in five years, on some platform,
telling you that you missed the golden era
of Facebook and Instagram,
because now it's appropriately priced.
And you guys have heard me,
if you follow me, say this.
I regret that I wasn't able
to build my dad's business bigger
because I didn't spend enough on Google.
I didn't spend enough.
I had it figured out.
It was called Google AdWords.
It was working.
Yet I still was doing
newspapers, and direct mail,
and radio, and television,
because I didn't understand the context
of the moment that I was living in.
♪ And they just laugh ♪
♪ When I said my name was Nick ♪
♪ I went home feeling sick but ♪
♪ Knew I couldn't quit ♪
♪ But little did they know ♪
♪ That God granted me this gift ♪
♪ I was broke inside my pockets ♪
♪ But my mind was feeling rich ♪
(audience applauds)
♪ Look, this is my destiny ♪
♪ This is God's plan ♪
♪ Even if you get the best of me ♪
You know, you make money off of that.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- What, so you make money about being you?
You know how hard it is
being, making money being you?
- No, I just want to talk.
- I get it, but you
don't want to just talk.
Then you wouldn't care
about how you're growing.
Like, you want to do
something else with it.
- Yeah.
- You don't want to just talk.
Otherwise, if you just want to
talk you'd be happy as fuck.
Because you're talking.
Got it?
- Yeah.
- You've gotta be patient.
You sure can, I would love to see it.
Hi.
- Hi.
You speak Russian?
- Thank you.
Yeah. (speaks foreign language)
- All right, real quick.
- Go fast.
Thank you for coming.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
Thank you so much.
- I'd love to talk to you, your team.
- Thank you so much,
I hope you enjoyed it.
Thank you.
You're very kind.
- Hi, hi Gary.
- How are you?
- How you doing?
- I'm very well.
- Of course, man, I felt it.
- Thank you, thank you.
- Inspiration, man.
- You're welcome, brother.
- Thank you very much.
- Thanks for coming, I hope you enjoyed.
You enjoyed it?
- Thanks, buddy, yeah.
- Kind of an oldie, 42.
- I love it man.
Thank you very much.
You're welcome.
Take care.
Hi.
Good?
- Yeah, really good.
- How are you?
- Thanks so much.
- You're welcome.
- Hope you liked our promo video.
- Thank you guys.
- Thank you.
- Hope you enjoyed it.
- Travel hat, travel hat.
- Yes!
DRock!
I will wear it, I will wear it.
- Cheers.
- Thank you so much, cheers.
- Thanks, man.
- Thank you so much, man, take care.
- Thank you.
- My hero.
- Thank you, darling.
- Love your stuff, man.
- Thank you, brother.
- That was really good, I love your work.
- Thank you, thank you so much.
Hi!
Thank you for your question.
- Thank you.
- And how are you?
- Good, thank you.
- Good to see you.
- How are you doing?
- Yeah, I'm good.
Thank you for coming.
- Keep it up, see ya.
- Cheers.
- [Man] My man!
- My man.
- How are you doing, brother.
- Thank you so much, brother, stay well.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you, this is my son as well.
- Love it, DRock.
- [DRock] I got it.
- Talk, talk.
Walk and talk.
- Hey, I'm 15.
- Pleasure.
Hi.
- Very nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- My boyfriend's obsessed with you.
- It's such a pleasure.
- Thank you.
- Thanks for coming.
- Thanks for coming, brother.
- All right, can I ask you
a quick, quick question?
- Go, go.
- The best way to network?
- How are you?
- Fine, nice to see you.
Thank you.
- Thank you, thanks for coming.
How are you?
- Hi, Gary.
- Thank you, man, good to see you.
Thank you, brother.
How are you?
Nice to meet you.
- Sorry, thank you for your time.
- No worries.
- Thanks for coming, brother, cheers.
How are you?
- Thank you.
- Pleasure.
How are you, my man?
- I'm all the better for seeing you.
- Thank you, brother, take care.
Thank you for coming, brother.
Thank you for coming.
- Cheers, man, thanks a lot.
- Cheers, stay well.
- Don't envy you right now.
- (laughs) I'm flattered, man.
- Good, thank you.
- Pleasure to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
All right, thank you for your question.
- No problem, thank you for answering.
- Thank you.
DRock, DRock, don't lose this.
How are you?
- Keepin' it too vain.
- Come work for Medal of Hope,
would you do, get like, half price?
- Happy to hear about it, happy.
- And we're doing stuff
ahead of deep mine, so.
- Thanks for coming, man.
(speaks foreign language)
- Can I ask you a question?
- Of course.
- I want a picture.
- Yes, brother.
- You changed my life,
man, changed my life.
- Thank you brother,
that makes me so happy.
- I dropped out of college, six figures.
(indistinct speech)
- My company is--
- Good job, thank you.
- Good to see you, thank you.
Thank you, my friend.
Such a pleasure.
Thank you.
- Please read this.
- For me?
DRock.
- Chat and a gift, nice to meet you.
- Thank you, man.
- Nice to meet you, Gary.
- Nice to meet you, how are you?
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you, man.
- Okay.
- Thank you.
- Can I do this one?
- Thank you, man.
- Stay well.
- Thank you.
- Hi.
- Sorry.
- Hi, how are you?
- Hi, thank you so much.
- Huge case study on a dentist, yeah.
- Do you want one together?
- Gary.
- How are you?
- Totally awesome, I'm a big fan.
- I will lose the--
- Get the shoes, get the shoes.
- I made a black one that I
didn't tell anybody about,
that I'm going to put out next month.
- I went, where the fuck
did he get the black one?
(laughs)
- Thank you, love, but they took it.
- Hope you enjoyed it.
- I love.
- Hello.
- How are you?
- Hi.
- Hi, from Rome, Italy.
- Some of your dinners in.
- Thank you.
- Thank you, how are you?
- I'm good thank you, you?
- Thank you very much
for those, thank you.
- Thank you, brother, stay well.
- Thank you, thank you.
- A true entrepreneur and
like, a mentor online.
- How are you, how you doing?
- Good to see you.
How are you?
You got the perfect spot!
- How are you?
- I'm very good.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
- Hi.
- How you doing?
- Thank you.
- Hello, nice to meet you.
- Hi, how are you?
- Just love your work so much.
- Thank you, thank you.
- Cheers.
- [Man] Hi, Gary.
- [Gary] How are you?
(group cheers)
- [Man] Two seconds, bro, dude.
- Thank you so much, man.
Would you just say hello to everybody?
(all speaking at once)
- That's my diary, dude.
- Thank you, brother.
- Hey, you conquered, Gary.
- Five videos a day.
- There you go, thank you.
You good?
Cool, I gotta bounce.
You're welcome so much you guys, bye.
Welcome.
Awesome.
- [Woman] Thank you so much.
- Bye guys, love you.
This way?
No?
- That way.
- This way.
- And then.
- To the left?
- [Interviewer] How do you feel
about Gary swearing so much?
- [Mom] I'm okay with that.
- [Gary] She cursed her
ass off when I was a kid.
It was, Mom.
- [Mom] That's not true.
- [Man] It's authentic.
- [Gary] Mom.
- [Mom] It's not, I did, but in Russian,
it wasn't that offensive.
- [Gary] Yeah but, Mom,
I understood Russian.
(group laughs)
- Remember when I was calling
you from, remember, from play?
And my neighbor always said,
I don't know this word,
but it's a magic word.
The minute you say it, they run.
- [Gary] My mom would call us.
You know we were '80s babies,
so we're outside playing.
She would call us, she would call us.
We didn't want to stop playing.
And then she would say one thing,
and I mean it didn't matter
if it was bottom of the ninth,
two outs, bases loaded in a game.
If that one phrase came out,
I was in the house within a minute,
'cause I knew what was on the
other side of that one was.
My mom doesn't play, that was real shit.
Punching, punishing, slapping, slapping.
Mom, did you slap?
- [Mom] No.
- Get outta here.
- [DRock] It wasn't on camera at the time.
- Yeah, we needed DRock.
- [Mom] I did, I did.
But not like it was an age,
because it was acceptable in Russia.
- Yeah.
- [Mom] You spank kids.
- Mom, there was a belt
that hung over our.
Seriously.
This is why I laugh, when
people think about, like,
being sad at people's comments,
or when people would
tell me, like cursing.
I'd be like you have
no idea how I grew up.
If you think, you know,
Johnny49 from Alabama is
going to stop me cursing.
Thank you so much.
- [Man] Welcome to Four Seasons.
- Thank you very much.
- How are you?
- Very good, how are you?
Thank you for having me,
Gary, thank you so much.
(speaking foreign language)
- I'm gonna teach you Russian
if you wanna be in Moscow.
- [Man] And enjoy your dinner.
- Thank you so much.
- [Man] You're very welcome.
Yeah.
(speaking foreign language)
Hello, how are you?
Good to see you.
Russian speaking.
We can probably target people in Brooklyn,
who would create word of
mouth for a Moscow event.
- [Mom] Oh, I agree.
(speaking foreign language)
- Oh, here we go.
Thank you so much.
Hello, hello.
How are you?
Yes, thank you.
Mom, you want some?
- Thank you.
- Thank you, brother.
How are you?
Thanks for joining.
Thanks for coming.
- Thank you.
- How are you?
Thanks for coming.
This is awesome.
- [DRock] Yeah, really cool.
- This is nice.
- Hi, Gary.
- Thanks for joining, man.
- No problem, thanks for having us.
- Thanks for coming, man.
Appreciate it.
Hey, brother.
Thanks for joining, man.
- Thanks for coming, man.
- Real pleasure.
- This is amazing, thank you.
- Thank you.
- Good to meet you, Gary.
- Thank you, this is really nice.
This is fuckin' fancy.
(laughs)
- Good to see you.
- I know, I'm like, this
is a long way from Belarus.
Great to see you.
- Thank you.
- Some kid comes up to me at the airport,
and I'm on my way to the Jets game
in Cleveland last Thursday
which did not work out,
so I'm still upset.
And he comes up to me, he goes,
Gary, I can't believe
I'm running into you.
I'm from Canada.
I just was here and I had
the worst day of my life.
I was scammed out of
all of my inheritance.
And I just came to New
York, and it's now done.
I've been scammed out of all my money.
And I looked at him, he
was a very young guy.
And I looked at him, and it was like,
and it was interesting
where I went with it,
because I'm a very compassionate dude.
But it was interesting, which
is why I'm excited for him.
My natural reaction was
more snarky than coddling,
which is usually my default.
I said, 'cause you wanted to
make too much money too fast.
And he looked at me, I
mean, I knew nothing.
I've talked to him for two seconds.
He goes, I've been scammed
out of all my inheritance,
and I said 'cause you wanted to make
too much money too fast.
And he goes, you're right.
And I was like, of course I'm right.
It was interesting, I'd never
had this kind of interaction.
I said, of course I'm right.
People don't get scammed
out of their inheritance
unless they're going for
something too good to be true.
Whether it's cryptocurrency,
which I'm very concerned about,
because people are getting ripped off.
Or a million other things.
But it's interesting.
Nobody pushes patience more than me.
Out of the truth of how
I live my life and too,
even if I didn't.
Much like, I don't read, or this and that.
Or I don't meditate.
It just very obviously works.
I think one of the mistakes
that a lot of people do,
when they're trying to
make a spread on a job,
is they're trying to drive down the cost
of their overhead to make the spread.
She's willing to pay me $50,000,
I'm going to hire him for 17
bucks an hour, him for $18.
He wants $22 but I fuckin' need $12.
This and that.
Because that's how I'm
going to make $11,000.
I think the way to do it,
and I don't know all the
details yet but I'm listening,
is to create a base and
incentivize the upside,
which creates more scale.
So you say to these two, you want $22?
I'll give you $32 if you
get it done in 24 hours.
What you're doing is,
one of the things that,
back to old school business,
my dad never wanted to pay anybody,
'cause that was where
the margin came from.
But then he de-incentivized
anybody to care.
- [Man] Exactly, then
they won't work for us.
- Correct.
So I think one of the ways to do it is,
go the other way and establish
a performance based model,
that makes less margin
in the beginning for you,
but by establishing pro worker,
you build a reputation and a brand
that brings you more and then
you can create your scale.
What my dad did extremely well
was he built a discount business,
that he didn't make as much
money as everybody else,
but he made it up in volume.
He might've made a dollar
where maybe others made three,
but by being the cheapest,
he sold 100 cases of
that rum versus seven.
And I think one of the things
you need to think about,
is create performance hurdles.
If him and him in that crew were so good.
If they crushed it.
You would only make 5% margin,
but they were thrilled,
and they start turning
down everything else.
Which allows you to do four jobs at 5%,
instead of one job at 15.
Do you see where I'm going?
- [Man] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So what you do is you create
a more incentivized model.
It makes less margin for you,
but then you get the best people,
who are making more money off of you.
You sit in the middle.
- [Man] Yeah yeah, I understand.
- You should try it.
- [Man] I will, definitely.
- [Mom] That's unbelievable.
- Thanks, mom. (laughs)
♪ This is my destiny ♪
♪ This is God's plan ♪
♪ Even if you get the best of me dog ♪
♪ You know now you
better quit testing me ♪
♪ You knock me down but you best believe ♪
- Let me say one thing.
When you laugh, you live.
When you're in a family business,
loving each other more than
the money, always works.
- That's the boss, dude.
- That's the boss of it.
For every 20, 25 year
old, a couple things.
One, you have to be patient.
Two, if you're lucky enough to have
this kind of beautiful hair,
you will dominate the world.
Three, most people 20 to 25
disproportionally value
other people's opinions,
and live their lives based on that.
The second you walk away from that,
you will be blown away by what can happen.
Appreciate it, brother.
What do you want?
- You tell me, buddy, you're the man.
- One life, do something with it.
- Exactly.
- Period.
Alexander, I'm very upset
that you're not here.
I have no idea why you're not here.
I'm baffled.
- Yes.
- We're very disappointed
in you, Alexander.
(laughs)
I'm very glad I'm not playing against you,
because I'm very emotional
when it comes to poker not in business.
Number two, and this
is important actually.
Because a lot of people, you
know, I grew up in the US.
I was older than a lot of the
kids that when poker exploded.
A lot of kids that blew up,
if you're watching right
now and you're under 30.
If you're under 30, if
you're 33 and under.
33 to 25.
Please understand that your ability
to be successful in poker,
I've watched a lot of you.
Half of you go to the dark side,
and use that capability to do dumb shit.
Half of you haven't figured out
how to go to the bright side.
But I will say this.
If you're great at poker,
you already have the
pieces to be great at life.
Use that to do good, not bad.
- That's gold.
- (laughs) If you want.
- Judgment is poison, don't judge others,
don't let them judge you.
And truth always wins in the end.
I think the biggest confusion
right now in society,
very simply, is that people see people
doing the wrong thing and
they think they're winning.
They're only winning at half time.
Good always wins in the end.
- [Man] Amen to that, brother.
- True right?
- [Woman] Yeah.
- I'll tell you my story.
- Please, I would like that,
I want to hear it actually.
- [Man] Can I have a picture with you?
- Yes.
- [Man] I have something for you.
- Amazing brother, thank you.
- These are fucking good.
- And I think these
are for better pictures
in your Instagram.
- I agree.
DRock's terrible at pictures.
(laughs)
DRock you're fired.
♪ Look, this is my destiny ♪
♪ This is God's plan even
if you get the best of me ♪
♪ This is my destiny ♪
♪ This is God's plan even if
you get the best of me, dog ♪